جدد وزير الخارجيه القطري محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني تمسك بلاده بحل الازمه
الخليجيه عن طريق الحوار مشيرا الى انه
خلال جولاته طلب من الدول الصديقه دعم
جهود امير الكويت في هذا الشان هذا وقد
اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي لافروف
دعم موسكو حل الخلافات على طاوله
التفاوض
السلام عليكم وتقبل الله صومكم كان هذا
اذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه الى اين تتجه مواقف القوى الدوليه
والاقليميه من الازمه الخليجيه وما
سيناريوهات الحل المحتمله في ظل توالي
الدعوات للحوار بين الاطراف
[موسيقى]
المعنيه الحوار بات الكلمه المفتاحيه في
التحر ركات الدوليه لمعالجه الازمه
الخليجيه الحاليه قالها وزير الخارجيه
الروسي سيرجي لافروف في محادثاته مع نظيره
القطري محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني الذي
اكد بدوره على حل الازمه في اطار مجلس
التعاون الخليجي وقد ابلغ الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان وزير الخارجيه البحريني
بضروره حل هذه الازمه قبل نهايه شهر رمضان
في هذا السياق بدا ملفتا التباين في
المواقف بين الرئيس الامريكي وادارته حيال
هذه الازمه قد استغرب وزير الخارجيه
القطري من اعتماد واشنطن في موقفها على
معلومات من دول اخرى رغم وجود قنوات اتصال
فعاله بين البلدين تقرير زياد
بركات هي اشياء لا تشترى هنا يبدو ان ما
كان بديهيا قد امتحن فاذا مواقف الدول
تتبدل بل تنقلب على ارثها فاذا من كان
صديقا بالامس وشريكا في مكافحه الارهاب
يغدو ممول له ومن اتهمه ترامب نفسه بتمويل
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه يصبح راس الحربه
فيما يراد له ان يكون تحالفا عريضا عربيا
واسلاميا لدحر الارهاب اليد نفسها التي
وقعت على صفقات تنوف على ال 400 مليار
دولار تصافح من يسعى البعض الى شيطنته وما
اكتفوا بذلك بل حاصروا بلاده جوا وبرا
واحكموا الحصار سريعا ما تبدا ما سماها
البعض بالصفقه بالاتضاع
يخرج ترامب فيتهم فكيف يستقيم ان تصافح
راس النظام في بلد ترميها بتمويل الارهاب
ذاك سؤال قد لا يعني ترامب الذي تردد انه
لا يعرف ان لبلاده جنودا وقاعده عسكريه في
قطر وان اجراءات بيعها طائرات اف 15 تتقدم
وان بعض المؤسسات الامريكيه لا ترى ما
يراه الرئيس ويقوله لعله الغموض بل
التضارب المقصود وقد يكون نتاج غياب رؤيه
بدات من اعتبار ايران عدوا لواشنطن والدول
العربيه الاربع المشاركه في حصار قطر
وانتهت بمحصر الدوحه ومحاوله خنقها لن
نستسلم يقول وزير الخارجيه القطري وقادرون
على الصمود الى ما لا نهايه وايا كانت
المالات فاننا متمسكون بالحوار حلا يقول
الرجل ذلك ويكرره في موسكو ومن قبلها
برلين وباريس وسواهما ثمه ما هو بالغ
الاهم
يقوله الرجل هنا ولعله موجه الى المؤسسات
الامريكيه فالعلاقات بين الدوحه وواشنطن
تمتد لعقود وهما شريكان في مكافحه الارهاب
فكيف والحال هذه تلجا واشنطن للحصول على
معلومات عن شريكها من دول اخرى كيف تفعل
هذا وثمه قنوات اتصال فعاله بين البلدين
لتبادل المعلومات تتشكل اذا وان على نحو
جنيني ما يمكن اعتبارها جبهه مضاده لتلك
التي تستهدف قطر الروس يريدون كما الدوحه
حلا على طاوله المفاوضات برلين تتقدم خطوه
الى الامام يتحدث وزير خارجيتها بلغه خشنه
عن الولايات المتحده ويحملها مسؤوليه
التصعيد يرى الرجل ان الدوحه مستهدفه في
وجودها نفسه وان ثمه حصارا مضروبا عليها
يتوجب رفعه على الفور يسمع القطريون لغه
شبيهه وان بلهجه اخف في باريس كلت عاصمتين
تبتعد عن موقف واشنطن وفي المنطقه هناك ما
هو اكبر من التصريحات تفعله انقره هنا
رئيس واجه انقلابا واصطفاف قطريا فوريا
الى جانبه انذاك يعلن اردوغان ان بلاده لن
تتخلى عن قطر يفعل اكثر يطالب وزير خارجيه
البحرين بضروره حل الازمه قبل نهايه رمضان
اما البرلمان التركي فيصادف على ارسال
قوات الى الدوحه ليس هذا فقط
بل ان هناك من يرى انها فرصه سنحت لدور
جديد في ظل تبدل المواقف والاحوال يصل
وزير الخارجيه الايراني سريعا الى انقره
هنا دولتان اقليميه كبيرتان يسوءه ما يجري
وله تتحسب الدوحه ليست وحيده
اذا نرحب بضيفي في هذه الحلقه هنا في
الاستديو الدكتور ابراهيم فريحات استاذ
النزاعات الدوليه في معهد الدوحه للدراسات
العليا ومن اليس صلاح القادري الاستاذ في
المعهد الاوروبي للعلوم الانسانيه في
باريس اهلا وسهلا بكم اهلا فيك دكتور
فريحات كيف ترى المنحى العام للمواقف
الدوليه الان تجاه ما يجري ا الموقف
الدولي هو بحقيقه الامر يعني تشكل وناضج
باتجاه واحد وهو الحل في اطار المفاوضات
ولا بديل عن ذلك يعني هناك شبه اجماع في
الموقف الدولي على هذه المساله ان الحل هو
ضمن الحوار ولا غير ذلك الشاذ الوحيد
للموقف الدولي هو موقف ترامب وليس موقف
الولايات المتحده وبالمناسبه هذا الشاذ
الذي يثبت القاعده يعني الطبيعي ان يكون
ترامب لا يتفق مع المجموع الدولي واذا كان
يتفق هنا تصبح المشكله فهذا هو الوضع
الطبيعي ان ترامب هو يختلف او يشذ عن
الموقف الدولي وما زلنا نرى ان هناك
انقسام في الموقف الامريكي ما بين المؤسسه
المتمثله بالبنتاجون ووزاره الخارجيه
وبقيه المؤسسات وم م قف ترامب وحتى
التويتس اللي عملها التي قام بها ترامب
مؤخرا هي كانت يعني تصدر من حسابه الشخصي
وليس من
الحساب الرئيس فاذا هناك موقف دولي متشكل
الموقف الدولي هذا مبني على قاعدتين
اساسيتين اولا
ان الاولويه هي الارهاب واي معارك
جانبيه عوضا عن مواجهه الارهاب هي على
حساب الهدف الرئيسي الذي الذي يتجه
باتجاهه والموقف الاوروبي تحديدا
والامريكي ناضج بهذا الاتجاه ويدفع بهذا
الاتجاه تركيز الجهود باتجاه محاربه
الارهاب والقضيه الثانيه ان ال ان الازمه
هي تحدث في منطقه حيويه في العالم في
منطقه الخليج وهي اهميتها بالنسبه لاسواق
النفط العالميه بالنسبه ل التجاره الدوليه
والكثير من القضايا ف هذا الموقف الدولي
لا يحتمل ان تحدث يعني ازمه وتتطور في
منطقه الخليج لهذا السبب اعتقد اننا راينا
هذا الاجماع سواء كان من موسكو او برلين
او فرنسا او الى اخره نعم على ذكر فرنسا
والموقف الاوروبي سيد صلاح القادري الموقف
الالماني تميز
بلهجه قويه صارمه للتنديد بالخطوات التي
اتخذها الثلاثي الخليجي ولكن في نفس الوقت
ايضا لاول مره وزير الخارجيه الالماني
يشير الى او يحذر من امكانيه وصول الامر
الى الى الى حرب كيف يمكن قراءه الموقف
الاوروبي ضمن هذه الصوره
الدوليه الموقف الاوروبي يظن انه يحكمه
معطى في الفتره الاخيره وهو انتخاب ترامب
والاجتماع الذي حصل في اطار حلف الناتو في
الفتره الاخيره والتصريح الشهير الذي قامت
به انجيلا ميركل يختصر هذا الشعور الجمعي
الذي هو موجود عند الطبقه السياسيه
الاوروبيه في الفتره الاخيره وهي حينما
قالت اننا يجب ان نعتمد على على انفسنا
نحن كا اوروبيون وان ينتهي وان ينتهي
اعتمادنا على امريكا وعلى على الناتو بهذا
الشكل اذا هم فهم القضيه والازمه الحاصله
الان في دوله الخليج ان الفاعلين الظاهرين
في هذه المساله هي الامارات والسعوديه
ودول الخليج بشكل عام ولكن ال القضيه
والازمه بالاساس هي محكومه هو صراع على
النفوذ صراع على نفوذ اطراف اقليميه
تحكمها الامارات والسعوديه التي يريد ان
تقضي على السياسه الخارجيه القطريه واي
صوت يشذ في البيت الخليجي وكذلك ذلك صراع
نفوذ ومصالح يقوده دونالد ترامب في شخصه
وهذا وهذا النفوذ هو نفوذ قد يكون نفوذا
اقتصاديا من خلول خلال الحصول على عقود
وصفقات جاوزت ال 450 مليار اياما قبل
بدايه هذه الازمه وانطلاقتها الامر الثاني
كذلك هو هو نفوذ عسكري في اطار ما يحصل
هذا التماهي والتداخل الحاصل بين شخصيه
دونالد ترامب والمشروع الروسي في في
المنطقه في الشرق الاوسط اذا هذان
المعياران هم الذان
يحكمان الموقف السياسي الموقف السياسي
الاوروبي الموقف السياسي الاوروبي يدفع
نحو الحوار وضد التصعيد وهذا تقريبا
الموقف السياسي الاوروبي هو الموقف الوسط
بين الموقف التركي وبين الموقف بين موقف
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهو قريب الى
موقف الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كمؤسسات
وليس كشخص الرئيس الذي هو دونالد ترامب
اذا هو موقف وسط بين الطرف الذي الداعم
الذي هو الموقف التركي وبين الطرف ال
الدول العربيه التي وقفت الى جانب
الامارات والسعوديه هو موقف وسط قريب الى
الموقف المؤسساتي الامريكي نعم بالنسبه
للموقف التركي تحديدا دكتور ابم ابراهيم
فريحات ايه يعني هل تعتقد بان القرار الذي
اتخذه
البرلمان يعد سابقا في طبيعه الانتشار
العسكري في منطقه الخليج وبالتالي هو
معطى يعني ملفت بشكل خاص
هو بالتاكيد ملفت ولكن يجب التذكير ان
الموقف التركي هو لم يتطور في غضون 24
ساعه اولا الاتفاقيه ما بين دوله قطر
وتركيا هي بدا التحضير لها منذ عام 2015
فهي ليست بجديده ما حدث مؤخرا هو التسريع
في عمليه المصادقه ومناقشتها في البرلمان
وتمت المصادقه بوقت قياسي و باغلبيه كبيره
في داخل البرلمان الموقف التركي بحقيقه
الامر هو احدث نوع من اعاده موازين القوى
الى الى نصابها وهذا باعتقادي اللي هو
يعني ساهم
بتخفيف الخطر الذي قد يتشكل عن هذه الازمه
فعندنا في النزاعات الدوليه عندما يكون
هناك اختلال فاضح في الموازين القوى هذا
يدفع باتجاه العنف وباتجاه التصعيد
وباتجاه الحرب ولكن عندما يكون هناك شبه
نوع من الموازنه في في في الموازين القوى
او المعادله في هذه الموازين فهذا يجعل من
التصعيد تحديدا العسكري او العنيف هو يحسب
له اكثر من حس اكثر من مره قبل الدخول في
بهذه المواجهه ولكن الخطوره في هذه القضيه
انه عندما يحدث هناك توازن في القوى وهو
ما نرى ان الموقف هو تحديدا بفعل دخول
الموقف التركي يحدث نوع من التوازن انه قد
يدخل المنطقه في الازمه في نوع من الجم
الستيل ميت الذي نسميه وهو قد يمتد الى
فرصه طويله ولكن بنفس الوقت هو يعطي فرصه
الى الحل لانه بهذه بهذه الحاله هي ليست
يعني تصبح الموضوع بحاجه الى حل حتى لا
تخسر اطراف جميع فدخول العامل التركي هو
فعلا شكل نوع من السابقه من ناحيه اعاده
اعاده موازين القوه الى نصابها وبالتالي
يسهل من اجل الدخول في حل او الحل عن طريق
الحوار ازمه ايضا سيد صلاح القادري فتحت
الباب ل تنسيق
ايراني تركي او على الاقل لنقل ليس تنسيق
وانما على الاقل هناك اتفاق بين انقره
وطهران على ان هذه الازمه يجب ان تحل ب عن
طريق الحوار ووزير الخارجيه الترك الرئيس
التركي اشار الى ان هذه المساله يجب ان
تحل قبل نهايه
رمضان تقديرك هذا العنصر ال ال التركي
الايراني سيلعب دورا
مهما لا يمكن سواء اتفقنا ام ام ام
اختلفنا مع السياسه الايرانيه في المنطقه
في في الفتره الاخيره ولكن لا يمكن انكار
ان ايران بالسياسه الامريكيه سياسه باراك
اوباما اصبحت فاعلا قويا واساسيه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وفي المنطقه العربيه خصوصا
في في
المشرق هذه القوه التي اكتسبتها ايران
خلال سياسه باراك اوباما في الفتره
الاخيره بالاضافه وال الاكبر خطا واكبر
خطر من هذه الازمه الخليجيه هو دفع هو دفع
دوله عيه مثل قطر و مثل دوله قطر الى
احضان الحضن الايراني وهذا اكبر خطا ا
اولا والثاني الخطر والخطا الثاني هو ان
يصبح الفاعلون الاساسيون تغييب الدور
العربي في هذه المنطقه بعد الذي حصل في
العراق بعد الذي حصل في سوريا تق بدا
الحضور العربي يخف وينقص بشكل قوي جدا
الزمه الاخيره التي التي افتعل التي قامت
بها السعوديه والامارات بدعم ترامب زادت
واضعف الموقف العربي والحضور العربي و
وشكلت حاله من الفراغ الاستراتيجي العربي
في المنطقه اذا هذا هو الخطر الكبير الخطر
الكبير هو زياده الفراغ الاستراتيجي
العربي في المنطقه هو دفع قطر الى القيام
بتحالف لان القضيه قضيه وجود وقضيه بقاء
والقرار التركي الذي اتخذ في الفتره
الاخيره بارسال ارسال نشر قوات عسكريه في
في قطر هو رساله مبطنه ورساله ظاهره لم
تكن مبطنه الى السعوديه والامارات على ان
اي محاوله للقيام بفعل عسكري ستجد مواجهه
من طرف تركيا في المنطقه كل هذه التصرفات
التي قامت بها التي التي نتجت او النتائج
التي التي افرزتها هذه الازمه في الفتره
الاخيره جعلت الفاعلين الاساسيين في
المنطقه بالاضافه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الخليج هو ايران وتركيا
والزمت قطر بصناعه تحالف او الانفتاح على
على الايران وعلى الايرانيين وعلى الاتراك
وان كان
عمليا الناحيه الدبلوماسيه المواقف
التركيه اقوى من الناحيه الاقتصاديه فتحت
انقره جسرا اقتصاد جسرا لنق الموا
الاقتصادي وعسكريا كذلك هي الدوله التي
قامت ب بقرار نشر هذه القوات اذا الى حد
الان ايران وجودها رمزي دبلوماسي اكثر مما
هو وجود حقيقي في الميدان طالما الكل يدعو
الى الحوار الان نريد ان نعرف بعد الفاصل
ما هي سيناريوهات الحل المحتمله للازمه
الخليجيه في ظل توالي كل هذه الدعوات
للحوار بين الاطراف المعنيه لنا
[موسيقى]
عوده
انا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها مواقف القوى
الكبرى تجاه الازمه الخليجيه الراهنه
والدفع باتجاه حلها عبر الحوار دكتور
ابراهيم فريحات بالنسبه
للحل هل هل تراه ممكنا في ظل هذه
الاجراءات التي كانت عاليه السقف بدرجه
تشبه الخطوه المقبله هو اعلان حرب لا لا
اكثر كيف يمكن النزول من هذه الشجره اذا
اردنا ان نتحدث عن حل و دعنا نتفق اولا ان
التصعيد اي بهذه بهذه الازمه هو وصل الى
الى سقف الى قمته الى النهايه يعني لا
يوجد تصعيد بعد ذلك لانه هناك بعد ذلك
يعني تكون الحرب والحرب انا باعتقادي انه
او الجه الخيار العسكري قد سقط ولا يكون
هناك لانه لا يوجد اي عامل يشجع بهذا
الاتجاه واهم هذه العوامل هو العامل
الدولي هذا يتركنا بخيارين الخيار الاول
او سيناريو هنا السيناريو الاول هو ان
ندخل في مرحله جمود وان يستمر الصعود الى
على الشجره هو لفتره معينه وبهذه الحاله
في مرحله الجمود والتي بالمناسبه نتجت عن
اعاده توازن القوه في المنطقه من خلال
تحديدا التدخل التركي
وهذا الجمود ممكن ان يطول الى فتره
والاطراف جميعها تخسر بهذا الاتجاه وهو
غير محبذ والمجموعه الدوليه انا باعتقادي
ليس لديها مستوى التحمل الترنس على على
الاستمرار في موضوع الجمود لان الجمود
ايضا هو يؤثر في الجانب الدولي بهذا
الاتجاه السيناريو الاخر هو الحوار
والحوار هنا حول قضايا حقيقيه يكون يعني
اذا كان هناك اسباب حقيقيه او اسباب التي
تدعو الى وجود الازمه ان ياتي هذه الاطراف
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الامارات مصر
بماذا تضر قطر في الامن الخليجي عندها
يكون هناك مجال للحديث حول هذه القضايا
ويكون كيف الحد منها وكيف توقفها وكيف
مقاومتها لكن حتى الان نحن يعني نلاحظ حسب
يعني المراقب من بعيد لا نرى ان الاهداف
الحقيقيه هي للازمه هي قد وضحت او لا نعرف
عن ماذا نتكلم يعني عندما يكون هنا هناك
حوار او عندما يكون هناك ازمه اول القضايا
نسال هي ما هي قضايا هذه هذا النزاع الاشي
او القضايا بهذا الاتجاه هي حتى الان غير
واضحه وبالنهايه باعتقادي بحاجه ان يكون
اولا ان يكون هناك وضوح في هذه القضايا
واذا كان في هناك هذه القضايا تضر بالامن
الخليجي سواء كان مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الامارات ان يتم الحوار كيف
يتم وقفها والحد منها وباعتقادي ستجد يعني
المملكه العربيه السعوديه موقف دولي داعم
باتجاه اللي هو وقف هذه المخاطر الامن
الخليجي اما اللي هو على قضايا اعلام ومش
اعلام والى اخره باعتقادي صعب جدا الحوار
حول قضايا من هذا النوع و وربما كان
ملاحظا بشكل
كبير سيد صلاح القادري ان هذا الموضوع
الذي يشير اليه الان دكتور فريحات غير
واضح لان حتى وزير الخارجيه القطري قال لم
نم لم نتسلم مطالب محدده واح اثلاث اربعه
يعني هي انتشرت اعلاميا لكن عمليا لا توجد
مطالب محدده هل تعتقد بان هذا
يبعد امكانيه
الحل عدم الوضوح في المطالب من الناحيه
الدبلوماسيه كان امرا امرا جليا وهذا ما
يجعل على ان الازمه لي لم تكن ازمه حقيقيه
بل هي كانت ازمه فقط صراع على نفوذ ولكن
المسائل الرئيسيه التي هي تمثل اختلاف بين
سياسه الام الامارات والسعوديه من جهه
وبين سياسه قطر اظن انها واضحه لا تتطلب
اقل شيء على مستوى التحليل السياسي لا
تتطلب خطابات سياسيه من طرف الفاعلين
الرئيسيين القضيه قضيه الربيع المواقف من
دول الربيع العربي قضيه الاخوان المسلمين
والقيادات الموجوده في في في قطر
قضيه الموقف من المقاومه الفلسطينيه وكذلك
قيادات الفلسطينيه على راسها خالد مشعل
موجوده في قطر
قضيه شبكه الجزيره بالاساس وكذلك السقف
العالي من حريه التعبير الذي هو يعتبر
اعلى سقف في الساحه العربيه القضيه
الخامسه وهي السياسه الخارجيه القطريه
التي تتمنع تتم التي تتمتع او تتسم تتسم
بالاحرى بنوع من التحرر
من
البيت السمت العام الخليجي هذه القضايه
الخمسه على اظن انها واضحه في اذهان
السياسيين القطريين ولكن هم يعلمون على ان
هذا ان السقف سيكون سقف عاليا وان التصعيد
كان تصعيدا كبيرا لذلك بالاضافه الى
التحرير استاذ ابراهيم انا اظن انه قضيه
الحوار مبنيه اساس على اساس نقطتين النقطه
الاساسيه الاولى وهي قناه الحوار وهذه
القناه بالاساس يجب ان تكون من الناحيه
الرمزيه تكون القناه الخليجيه وهي كما دع
السفير القطري في السفير القطري في في
ووزير الخارجيه القطري على ان تكون ان
تكون القناه و هي قناه الكويتيه وه وهو
مساعي الامير الكويتي اما بالنسبه ل ال
العوامل المحدده في تقدم في تقدم الحوار
اظن ان ان موقف الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وما ينتج عنه هذا التجاذب بين
المؤسسات الرسميه التي هي وزاره الخارجيه
والبنتاجون ووزاره الخارج ووزاره الدفاع
الامريكيتين من جهه وكذلك شخص ترامب من
جهه اخرى على اي على اي قاعده سوف يقف
الموقف الامريكي في الاخير هو المحدد هو
العامل المحدد في الدفع في ما هو الريتم
الذي ستتقدم به تتقدم به المفاوضات
والحوار ولكني كما قال استاذ ابراهيم انا
اميل اكثر على انها ستدخل الازمه في نوع
من الجمود السياسي الى فتره معينه في اطار
في اقل شيء في على على الاقل ان تحصل هناك
مسافه زمنيه معينه بين توقيع دونالد ترامب
على على ال 450 مليار والعقود التي استفاد
منها الاقتصاد الامريكي وبين بدايه جوله
للحوار تكون جاده
و ضغط امريكي كبير نعم ولكن حتى هذا
الجمود كما قل دكتور فريحات ليس ليس مريحا
هناك راي عام يعتقد بان هذه الازمه هي
الشجره التي تخفي الغابه هناك هناك شيء
اكبر بكثير من مجرد ازمه خليجيه مع دوله
قطر هل تعتقد بان هذا التصور من شهري ان
ان ان يعمق ايضا صعوبه الوصول الى حل انا
باعتقادي استاذ محمد هو يعني بهذا النوع
من الازمات والعوامل التي تصاحب وتحديدا
الموقف الدولي لا تسمح بتطور الموقف اكثر
من ذلك وبالنهايه لا يوجد هناك حل سوى
الحوار والحوار عن قضايا حقيقيه وليس عن
قضايا يتم استلامها من الاعلام او الى
اخره الص الوصول الى المواجهه العسكريه
انت تستبعده بالكامل انا استبعده على
الاقل ضمن الظروف او المعطيات الحاليه لا
يوجد هناك بالوقت الحالي اي مؤشر يسمح
بالمواجهه العسكريه باي شكل من الاشكال
لان الموقف الول وممكن ان نتحدث بهذا
الموضوع لساعات يعني ونسرد الشواهد التي
تمنع هذا الحديث في الوقت في الوقت الحالي
الا طبعا اذا حصل هناك تطورات يعني ضمن
معطيات مختلفه وهناك يكون لكل حادث حديث
لذلك نحن امام مرحله جمود وانا اتفق مع
زميلي من باريس ان نحن امام مرحله جمود
يعني ممكن ان يستمر لفتره طويله هذا
الجمود اخ محمد هو يعني س سيخسر الجميع
فيه الجمود السياسي سواء كان على مستوى
الاقتصادي ولكن اخطر من المستوى الاقتصادي
انا باعتقادي اللي هو المستوى ال يعني ال
الامني وحتى الاجتماعي في منطقه الخليج
حيث ان هذا النزاع يؤثر على النسيج
الاجتماعي في المنطقه الخليج وعلى جميع
الاطراف وليس على طرف واحد وسيعقد ازمات
عانت منها المنطقه لمرحله لمرحله طويله من
الزمن سوريا من يتحدث الان عن سوريا يعني
هل نسينا الحرب في سوريا هل نسينا
المعاناه الشعب السوري هل نسينا كل ما
يحدث في سوريا واصبحنا الان نتحدث عن
اغلاق قناه الجزيره او الحد او التاثير في
سياسات قناه الجزيره يعني هنا هذا يعني
حدث اللي هو نوع من الانحراف الكبير عن
المهمات التي تواجه المنطقه والتي هي
بحاجه عاجلا ام اجلا ان يتم الجلوس
والحوار فيها وفعلا اذا كان هناك قضايا
تمس في مصالح الدول الجاره ان يتم الحديث
فيها واخذ الاحتياطات ومواجهتها حتى حت لا
يحدث هذا والا يعني سيكون هناك ثمن خساره
لفتره طويله للاسف بدون نتيجه شكرا لك
دكتور ابراهيم فريحات استاذ النزاعات
الدوليه في معهد الدوحه للدراسات العليا
شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من باريس صلاح القادري
الاستاذ في المعهد الاوروبي للعلوم
الانسانيه في باريس بهذا مشاهدينا الكرام
نصل الى نهايه هذه الحلقه في امان
[موسيقى]
الله
ن